SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible] SEVEN SEVEN
GLAZER.
HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
[inaudible]
CHAIN HERE [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
DODD GALGIANI GALGIANI HERE HELL.
LEYVA.
PAN.
CAN HEAR WILK.
WELL HERE.
WE HAVE A A QUORUM AND WE HAVE --
Và WILL BEGIN WE HAVE ONE BILL
ON OUR AGENDA THIS MORNING SB
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
SENATOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT COMMITTEE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR WHO.
HAS REALLY TAKEN A DEEP DIVE ON
THIS ISSUE --
IN VERY GRATEFUL FOR OFFICE WORK
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE --
MISS HUCKLE ON THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TEAMED UP FOR ALL OF HER
ONCE AS WELL BUT I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL MISTER CHAIR FOR ALL OF
YOUR EFFORTS --
WITH THIS ISSUE.
MEMBERS BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO PROTECT
THOUSANDS OF CANVAS FARMERS IN
PARTICULAR.
WHO DID THE RIGHT THING AND
APPLIED FOR STATE LICENSE?
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF PROP.
SIXTY FOUR I'D THE TEMPORARY
LICENSE IS ABOUT TO EXPIRE.
IN BECAUSE THE INABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO EXTEND THEIR LICENSE DUE
TO EXISTING STATE LAW.
WHICH MEANS.
THESE FOLKS ARE ALL GOING TO BE
ABLE ARE ALL GONNA DROP INTO THE
ILLICIT BLACK MARKET.
THEIR IN ESTIMATED TEN THOUSAND
TEMPORARY LICENSES IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT WILL
EXPIRE. TWENTY THREE TODAY
TWENTY THREE TODAY WILL GO FROM
LEGAL TO ELICIT.
AT NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
THIS IS THE WORST WAY TO
TRANSITION A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL CROP WHICH
EMPLOYS THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
WITHOUT LEGAL LICENSES THERE
ISN'T A LEGAL REGULATED MARKET.
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE AS THE
CHAIR DID --
OVER THE PAST TWO WEEKS.
UNTIL THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE STATE'S LICENSING
AUTHORITIES WERE ABLE TO ISSUE
FOUR MONTH TEMPORARY LICENSES TO
APPLICANTS.
WITH OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXTENSION.
THE TEMPORARY LICENSES REQUIRED
PROOF OF LOCAL AUTHORIZATION AND
ENTITLE LICENSE HOLDERS TO GAUGE
IN COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY
WITHOUT COMPLETING THE MANDATED
ANNUAL LICENSING APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING SEEKER
REVIEW [inaudible]
THAT'S AMENDED.
BUT TO BE A TO GET HIM IN THE
SYSTEM.
THERE IS AN EXCEPTION MADE RIGHT
THING TO DO. TO BUY MORE TIME
FOR THE LOCALS CONDUCTS SEEK
REVIEWS THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR PASSED SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE WHICH AUTHORIZED A
LICENSING AUTHORITY STATE AGENCY
FOR EXAMPLE TO ISSUE A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE TO AN
APPLICANT.
IF THE APPLICANT HOLDS A TEMPER
LICENSE NUMBER ONE DEMONSTRATED
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH SEEK
WHAT NUMBER TWO AND WHILE LOCAL
REVIEW WAS STILL CARRYING.
THE APPLICANT COMPLETED ALL
OTHER PORTIONS OF THE
APPLICATION.
BUT TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT HERE
JUST BECAUSE OF SICK WHAT REVIEW
OR TRYING TO G. SEQUEL
COMPLAINTS.
WERE HERE BECAUSE STATE
DEPARTMENTS BEEN PROCESSING THE
TEN THOUSAND TEMPORARY LICENSES
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
IN THIS IS CONFUSING ANGLER
THROW UP A QUICK CHART MISTER
CHAIR IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU.
SO ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE ARE TEN THOUSAND TEN
THOUSAND TEMPORARY LICENSES.
SYDNEY TEN THOUSAND LICENSES
TOTAL.
YOUR TEMPORARY LICENSE TO FIND A
IN ORGANIC CANNABIS FARMER.
I HAVE A TEMPER LICENSE FOR A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS.
AND THEN I CAN GET A NINETY DAY
EXTENSION.
BUT PER STATE LAW THAT NINETY
DAY EXTENSION CANNOT BE ISSUED
PAST DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO THE
DEPARTMENTS ISSUED A LOT OF
EXTENSIONS.
OVER SIX THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
WERE ISSUED BY THE CALVET
APARTMENT OF FOOD NAG ALONE.
THE SECOND STEP AS FAR AS LIKE
THE SCENE S A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE.
IT'S VALID FOR ONE YEAR.
OUT OF THE SIX THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED THAT WERE SENT TO CDFA.
ONLY FOR PROVISIONAL LICENSES
FOR HAVE BEEN ISSUED.
FUNDING TO JUMP DOWN ALL THE WAY
TO ANNUAL LICENSES. FIVE IN
ANNUAL LICENSE THAT MEANS I AM
FREE AND CLEAR TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE --
MY CANNABIS FARM FOR EXAMPLE.
OUT OF ALL DEPARTMENTS
[inaudible] ZERO PUBLIC HEALTH
IS WELL AS CDFA.
ONLY FIFTY TO FIFTY TWO ANNUAL
LICENSES.
HAVE BEEN ISSUED.
ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS.
SO -- YOU
CAN SEE THAT THIS IS MORE THAN
JUST A SEEK WHAT COMPLIANCE
ISSUE.
AND THE MONTH OF MARCH ALONE
OVER ONE THOUSAND TEMPORARY
GROWING LICENCES ISSUED BY CD.
COVER DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG ARE
SET TO EXPIRE.
THE STATE UNDER CURRENT LAW HAS
NO ABILITY AS WE JUST SAW TO
EXTEND A TEMPORARY LICENSE
DESPITE THE FACT THOUSANDS ARE
SET TO EXPIRE. TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE THOUSANDS OF APPLICANTS
WHO WANTED TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW IN APPLIED FOR TEMPORARY
LICENSE DID SO IN THE LAST
QUARTER OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
LEAVING A MASSIVE BACKLOG FOR
THE STATE REGULATING AGENCIES.
TO BE CLEAR.
WE GAVE ALL THESE FOLKS WHO
WANTED TO BE A TO COME IN FOR
TEMPORARY LICENSE UNTIL DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TO BE ABLE TO APPLY.
AS A TEMPORARY LICENSE IS COME
DO IF THE STATE CAN'T APPROVE OR
DENY AN ANNUAL LICENSE PRIOR TO
TEMPER LICENSE EXPIRING THE
LICENSE HOLDER FOR EXAMPLE IF
I'M A FARMER DISTRIBUTOR
RETAILER.
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
OPERATE LEGALLY AND WILL BE
AUTOMATICALLY KICKED BACK INTO
THE BLACK MARKET.
THIS ALSO MEANS THE FLOW LEGAL
CANNABIS IS AT RISK TO RETAILERS
WHICH VERY WELL COULD MEAN.
ENHANCE RELIANCE.
ON BLACK MARKET CANNABIS AT THE
RETAIL LEVEL.
THE EXACT ISSUE.
WE WANT TO AVOID.
WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT CREATING
THE ENTIRE LEGAL STRUCTURE FOR A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR CANNABIS
MARKET IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
WAS LIKE BUILDING AN AIRPLANE
WHILE WE'RE FLYING IN.
AND THAT'S WHEN THE REASONS WHY
WE'RE HERE IN MY WE WERE WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM WOOD.
TO BUILD INTERVIEWS SB SIXTY
SEVEN WHICH DOES IT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE BEER OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO EXTEND TEMPORARY
LICENCES BY LICENSEES WHETHER A
NEW APPLICATION IS BEING PROCESS.
SO AS LONG AS THE ANNUAL
APPLICATION WAS IN BEFORE THE
TIMBER EXPIRED.
THE EXTENSION OF THIRTY WILL
EXPIRE ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR.
NUMBER.
TWO SB SIXTY SEVEN IMPROVES THE
PROVISIONAL ANNUAL LICENSE
PROCESS IN THE STATE IT
CLARIFIES THAT IF IT'S WITHIN
THE STATE AGENCIES SOLE
DISCRETION THEY CAN CONVERT A
TEMPORARY LICENSE. TO A
PROVISIONAL ANNUAL.
IT ALLOWS LICENSING AUTHORITIES
ARE GRANT PROVISIONAL LICENSE IS
TO LOW'S WITHOUT TEMPORARY
LICENSES ONCE THE BACKLOG OF
APPLICATIONS FOR THOSE WITH
TEMPER LICENSES IS RESOLVED
FINALLY.
ON PROVISIONALS IT EXTENDS
PROVISIONAL LICENSES TO JULY
FIRST --
TWENTY TWENTY OF THE CURRENT
JANUARY FIRST INSTEAD OF THE
CURRENT GENERATION FIRST --
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EXPIRATION.
FINALLY AND I'M GONNA STOP
TALKING MISTER CHAIR --
SB SIXTY SEVEN REQUIRES ANY
LICENSING AUTHORITIES STATE
DEPARTMENT WHO USES THE
EXTENSION OF STORY TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN METRICS THE LEGISLATURE
WE HAVE TO BE TRACKING THIS.
HOW MANY TEMPORARY LICENSES
LICENSEES HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
AND YOUR APPLICATIONS HOW MANY
HAVE NOT BEEN HOW ME TEMPORARY
LICENSES HAVE EXPIRED?
IN THIS ALL HAS TO GO TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW THE
PROVISIONAL ANNUAL APPLICATIONS
ARE BEING PROCESS. TO BE CLEAR
SB SIXTY SEVEN CREATES A SHORT
TERM SOLUTION TO AVOID AN
IMPENDING CRISIS THAT IS
CURRENTLY AT OUR DOORSTEP NOW.
AND SET UP ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR HALFWAY
FOR CREATING A THRIVING GREEN
MARKET PLACE FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE AND THAT IS REALLY WHERE
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO.
IS.
THIS IS A BANDAID. TO A BIG
CHALLENGE BUT IT BUYS US
BREATHING ROOM. FOR A BIG FIX.
TO HAVE TODAY A TERROR CARVER
HERE EXACTLY DIRECTOR WITH THE
HUMBLE COUNTY GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WHO WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO GET BACK BECAUSE OF
FLOODED ROADWAYS --
IN LINDSAY ROBINSON EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO
BE TO PROVIDE COMING IN AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR GONNA SAY SINCERELY
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR WORK IN YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU CENTER REQUIRED BUT
HAPPY DEAL THIS HERE YOUR
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SENATORS --
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TERRA CARVER AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE HUMBLE
COUNTY GROWERS LANCE
REPRESENTING OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY LICENSED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WORKING IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY.
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
SIXTY SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN HUMBOLDT COUNTY PASSED
THE FIRST LAND USE ORDINANCE
REGULATING COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WILL HUMBOLDT COUNTY REPRESENTS
JUST A FRACTION OF 1% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION HUMBLE HOLDS
23% OF THE STATE'S TEMPORARY
CULTIVATION LICENSES
REPRESENTING OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
INDEPENDENT BSINESSES.
WHILE WE ARE SMALL IN POPULATION
WERE PRETTY MIGHTY WHEN IT COMES
TO CANNABIS FARMING AND WE'RE ON
TO AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP WITH
OVER FIFTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.%
AS EARLY AS THE DOCTORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND%
HUMBOLDT OR THE FIRST TO STEP
FORWARD AND COMPLY WITH
REGULATIONS.
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT DETECTS AS A RESULT
THESE BUSINESSES OF SPENT THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY AND
STATE AGENCIES TO DO JUST THAT.
WHILE ADAPTING TO AN EVER
CHANGING ARE CHANGING REGULATORY
CLIMATE.
MANY OF THE BUSINESSES TEMPORARY
LICENSES ARE SET TO EXPIRE IN
THE NEXT MONTH OR TWO A FEW
ALREADY HAVE RENDERING THEM
UNABLE TO CONDUCT BUSINESS.
WHAT WE BELIEVE WITHOUT THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL THERE WILL
BE DIRE CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
ANIMATE MARKET COLLAPSE?
OF HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES WITHIN
THE REGION AND THROUGHOUT THE
REST OF THE STATE.
THE WHOLE COUNTY GORE'S LANDS
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
MCGUIRE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD IN AG AND
THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND AGREEING TO TAKE ON THIS
ISSUE IN HERE THIS CRITICAL BILL
TODAY.
WERE SINCERELY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS
POLICY CONTAINED IN SB SIXTY
SEVEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO SEE THIS BILL
APPROVED AND SIGNED INTO LAW AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
IN YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT WITNESS HI
GOOD MORNING I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING A LITTLE TARDY WE WERE
HOSTING --
WEAPON ARE WITH THE BEER OF
CANNABIS CONTROL AND I RAN A
LITTLE LATE --
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY ROBINSON AND
I'M THE EXACT DESTRY ASSOCIATION.
CCI A AS WERE ALSO KNOWN WAS
FORMED IN TWENTY TWELVE TO UNITE
THE CAN'T ILLEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. TO HELP EDUCATE AND
ACT AS A RESOURCE TO LAWMAKERS
AND OUR MEMBERS.
WERE THE MOST INFLUENTIAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION IN THE STATE
REPRESENTING THE DIVIDE THE
DIVERSE INTERESTS OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY INCLUDING
RETAIL CULTIVATION MANUFACTURING
DELIVERY DISTRIBUTION.
CASTING INSURANCE PACKAGING AND
VARIOUS ANCILLARY SERVICES ARE
UNIFIED VOICE INCLUDES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
REPRESENTING SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY BRANDS AND NEARLY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT THE TATE.
C. C. I. A. IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIXTY SEVEN
AND I'D LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
SB SIXTY SEVEN ALLOWS THE
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS BUSINESSES
THAT WERE ISSUED TEMPORARY
CANNABIS BUSINESS LICENSES PRIOR
TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
TO REMAIN OPERABLE UNTIL THE
STATE LICENSING AGENCIES PROCESS
ANNUAL APPLICATIONS.
THIS TEMPORARY LICENSE PROGRAM
WHICH WAS ENACTED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WAS ESTABLISHED TO ALLOW
CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO OPERATE
WHILE THE STATE LICENSING
AGENCIES DEVELOP PROCESS AND
REVIEW.
APPLICATIONS FOR ANNUAL LICENSES.
LAST YEAR WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT THE TEMPORARY STRUCTURE IT
WOULD IT WOULD EXPIRE BEFORE
MANY OF THE ANNUAL APPLICATIONS
WERE REVIEWED AND ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONAL LICENSE CATEGORY WAS
CREATED TO PASS BE. FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE TO GIVE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES AND THE INDUSTRY
ADDITIONAL TIME TO COMPLETE THIS
PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
CREATION OF PROVISIONAL LICENSES
CURRENT DATA SHOWS THAT UNLESS
ADDRESSED.
NEARLY SO --
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED TEMPORARY
LICENSES WITH ASIANS COULD
EXPIRE BY APRIL OF THIS YEAR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE PROVIDE
PATHWAYS TO KEEP COMPLIANT
BUSINESSES WHO ARE TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING WITHIN THE LEGAL
SYSTEM.
BUSINESSES AND POSSESSION OF
TEMPORARY LICENSES HAVE WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD TO OBTAIN LOCAL
APPROVAL THEY HAVE INVESTED
HUNDREDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO MEET THE RIGOROUS
STATE.
COMPLIANCE STANDARDS WE CANNOT
AND SHOULD NOT ALLOW THESE
BUSINESSES TO FALL OUT OF THE
LEGAL SYSTEM FOR NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
FURTHER DATA HAS SHOWN THAT MANY
OF THE SOON TO EXPIRE LICENSES
BELONG TO CULTIVATORS AS TERROR
JUST ILLUMINATED.
THE ESSENTIAL STARTING POINT OF
THE CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN SHOULD
THESE BUSINESSES LAPSE IN THE
UPSTREAM RAMIFICATIONS FOR THE
ENTIRE CANNABIS INDUSTRY COULD
BE SEVERE.
THE PASSAGE OF SIXTY SEVEN IS
CRITICAL FOR THE CONTINUED
SURVIVAL OF THE LEADERS CAN A
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF OUR C. C. I. A. MEMBERS
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO OBTAIN
LYSONS AND BECOME COMPLAIN
OPERATORS IN THE CANNABIS SPACE.
AND THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN DANGER
OF FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS WE
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY STRENGTHENING
THE ILLICIT MARKET IF WE DO NOT
TAKE IMMEDIATE STEPS TO CURB
THIS PROBLEM. FOR THESE REASONS
I ASK YOU PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
LOOK INTO THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR IF YOU COULD
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND TO ME
TWO WOULD BE GREAT.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CO LEAVE --
THE LARGEST VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CAMPUS BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO US ON BEHALF OF
SITE FLOW KANA ON BEHALF OF THE
COVER CAME AS CAR YOU'RE SAYS HE
XIN ON BEHALF.
OF SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS LANCE
IN SUPPORT FOR CLIENTS THREE
LICENSES AFFECTED BY THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
PAUL HAS VERY LOVINGLY LEGALLY --
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD --
THE COULD REPEAT EVERYTHING THAT
WAS JUST SAID WERE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU KEEP YOU KNOW
COUNTY.
WE SEE SENATE BILL SIXTY SEVEN
AS A SAVIOR OF WOMEN AND MEN
LIKE US.
WE HAVE EXHAUSTED OUR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS OUT
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE QUIT AS
WITH KING TUNNEL WHAT'S HARTMAN
ON BEHALF OF CONNECTED CANNABIS
BREEZE AND THE CALIFORNIA CAMPUS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION ALL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MANY GRAMMARIANS ALMOND
TREMENDOUS YOU KNOW COUNTY I'M A
CULTIVATOR AS WELL AS THE
FOUNDER OF THE COUPLE OF
CANNABIS ADVOCACY GROUP WHICH WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED MEMBERS AND
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE S. THANK
YOU. FOR BEING HERE.
THE MISTER CHAIR MEMBER'S NAME
IS KEVIN CARMICHAEL HARVEST Là
GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHOCK WE HAVE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
MENDOCINO COUNTY. FOR MENDOCINO
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE REQUEST OF THE RURAL
COUNTIES --
RICK AND IN REGARDS TO THEIR
AMENDMENTS TO THE TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAM AND THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THE TEMPORARY
LICENSES --
THE EXTENSION OF THAT WINDOW --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
CARE MARTIN ST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORTER OUT WE
WERE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE LAST YEAR.
THAT CREATED THE PROVISIONAL
ANNUAL LICENSE PROCESS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE IMPROVED A
PROBLEM.
UPON PROCESS --
IN SB SIXTY SEVEN THAT EXTENDS
OUT OUT TO IT ALSO WILL ALLOW
LOCALS AND THE VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES TO TRANSITION THOSE
TIMES INTO THE PROVISIONAL
PROCESS.
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE AND THUS
NOT KICKING IN THE TRASH TRACK
AND TRACE EQUIREMENTS THINK
AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING ERIN ORDER ME HAVE
A CANVAS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VOLUMES GERMAN.
OUR WHEN WHEN THANK US SENATE
MCGUIRE ON BEHALF OF SEMI DRESS
ON BEHALF OF LONG POKE VALLEY
CAM ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OVER A HUNDRED CULTIVATION
FARMERS AND KNOW THE SUMMER
COUNTY.
WHO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU?
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
SCENE.
NINE LIKE TO ASK ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHTS SEE NOW GONNA CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING AND BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
A CENTER OF WIRE FIRST LET ME
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME --
EVEN OUT THERE --
AS A FORCEFUL ADVOCATE FOR HOW
WE CAN SET UP A FAIR AND HONEST
AND RESPONSIVE --
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS --
THIS PRODUCT AND DIED AND YOU
LEADERSHIP APPRECIATED BY ALL --
I DID THAT NOTICE THAT WE DIDN'T
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AG IS THERE ANYONE HERE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD IN AG.
IN THE ROOM.
I DID THAT MAKE A REQUEST
EARLIER --
TODAY TO ASK THAT A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM FOOD NAG GOT
BE PRESENT SENATOR REQUIRED YOU
KNOW DO THEY HAVE A POSITION ON
YOUR BILL.
THEY'VE NOT TAKEN A POSITION.
SO IT SEEMS THAT --
AND IS THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
FOOD DAGEN ANYWAY THE APPROACH
YOU AND ASK YOU TO CARRY THIS
LEGISLATION THEY DID NOT.
THIS IS AN AUTHORED SPONSORED
BILL YOU SEEN A PROBLEM.
A TRAIN CRASH COMING AND AND YOU
STEPPED UP TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO AVOID IT.
IN OUR OFFICE WE'D CALL THIS A
GOOD OLD FASHIONED HOT MESS.
THAT -- THAT
COULD ANSWER ANY MORE DETAILS ON
THAT EXCLAMATION [inaudible]
BUT OF FOOD IN AG IS.
HAS A BIG PART OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LICENSING --
CANNABIS CULTIVATORS.
THIS IS NOT A NEW THING FOR THEM
RIGHT ON THE MEDICINAL SIDE THEY
HAVE ALSO HAD THIS
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE PAST IS
THAT RIGHT.
EVEN ACTIVELY ENGAGE ON
MEDICINAL SIDE WITH THE PASSAGE
OF MAKARSKA A FEW YEARS BACK BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND WE'VE ALSO
KNOWN THAT THAT THIS DAY WAS
COMING FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
RIGHT SO IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S OF
A POINT OF BAFFLEMENT FOR FOR ME
AT LEAST IS THAT THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT JUST HAPPENED
YESTERDAY --
THE LEGISLATURE IN THEIR WISDOM --
TRY DO ANTICIPATE THIS PROBLEM
AND AND PROVIDED --
DISABILITY TO HAVE TEMPORARY
LICENSES SO --
THE PIPELINE WAS PRETTY CLEAR
FOR AWHILE IN TERMS OF THEIR
NEED TO THE PROCESS WITHIN
CERTAIN PERIODS OF TIME HAVE
THEY GIVEN YOU AN EXPLANATION AS
TO WHY --
THEY'VE HAD SUCH TROUBLE.
WE HAVE NOT HAD A CLEAR
EXPLANATION AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE A
FURTHER MEETINGS INTO THE WEEKS
TO COME.
ID GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING.
HAVE THEY ARE GIVING YOU ANY
OPINIONS AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS BILL WOULD RESOLVE THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE AND
OTHERS.
TERMS OF APPROPRIATELY LICENSING
FOR THE FRAMEWORK.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE DEPARTMENT
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS WE ARE
LEFT WITH NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE --
IF WE DO NOT PASS THIS BILL --
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE TRYING TO
COMPLY WITH THE NEWLY PASSED LAW
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FALLING
INTO THE ILLICIT MARKET.
IN FACT THAT WE'RE TAKING TEN
STEPS BACK IF WE ADVANCE THE
STATUS QUO POSITION --
AND LET THESE LICENSES EXPIRE SO
HAS THE DEPARTMENT GAVE ANY
INDICATION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS
MARKETPLACE LEGAL MARKETPLACE
WORK.
I THINK THAT --
IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
DEPARTMENTS --
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO COMPLY WITH PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR I THINK --
I'LL SPEAK FOR MYSELF ON THIS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS TRAIN COMING.
BUT THE LIGHT KEEPS GETTING
BRIGHTER.
AND IT'S ABOUT TO CRASH.
IN REGARDLESS OF YOUR OPINION ON
CANNABIS.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SPOKE LOUD AND
CLEAR.
WE NOW HAVE A LEGAL MARKET PLACE.
RENDON AT GO BACK. TWO SIX
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED THAT ARE
CURRENTLY WAITING --
TO BE PROCESSED [inaudible] FOR
FOUR HAVE BEEN ISSUED
PROFESSIONALS.
AND AND AGAIN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE THEY INDICATED
THEIR SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
I WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT --
I BELIEVE --
THEY THINK THAT THEY CAN GET
THIS RESOLVED --
THIS YEAR AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND I
GOTTA SAY.
THAT THE CAPTAIN APARTMENT A
FOOD NAG HAS BEEN WONDERFUL TO
WORK WITH ON ISSUES OF CANNABIS.
SINCE THE ISSUE OF EDICINAL
CANNABIS WAS PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED.
INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR BROWN
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY GOOD TO WORK
WITH THEY HAVE GREAT FOLKS.
AND ON THIS ISSUE CHOICE BUT TO
ACT AND I BELIEVE IF THIS
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT ACT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THOUSANDS THAT
WILL NOW BE VULNERABLE. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT RAIDS THAT ARE
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN WITH THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE BLACK MARKET.
SO --
EVERYONE I AWARE OF THAT
DEADLINES IN THE REQUIREMENTS.
YOU'VE POINTED OUT THAT --
OF THE THOUSANDS OF OF FOLKS WHO
ARE TRYING TO FOLLOW THE RULES
AND DO IT THE LEGAL WAY.
THAT ONLY A HANDFUL.
HAVE BEEN PROCESSED TO TO
FULFILL THAT REQUIREMENT --
ITS THE IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE THE
DMV -- THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD NOT BE A GOOD
SITUATION WELL.
I A I I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP --
THAT SOMEBODY'S PAYING ATTENTION
AND STEPPING UP I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD IN AG IS NOT HERE --
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH YOU
AND WITH THE LEGISLATURE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE DIFFICULTIES
THAT THEY'VE HAD.
ALTHOUGH THOSE ARE FOREIGN TO ME --
IS EXACTLY WHAT IS HOLDING UP
AND WHY AND I GUESS THE BIGGER
BROADER QUESTION FOR US IS A
COMMITTEE.
IS WHY THE THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE
THAT YOU HAVE IN THIS BILL IS
GOING TO PROVIDE THE LONG TERM
OLUTION. TO WHAT WE WANT --
AT A BY PROPRIOCEPTION LEGAL
MARKET PLACE FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO ANSWER IT.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE THE
DILEMMA THAT I HAVE --
IN LOOKING AT YOUR LEGISLATION
IS THAT.
I IT SEEMS VERY VERY NECESSARY
IN A THE THE RESOLUTION OF THIS
ISSUE.
AS WE GO FORWARD AND IF THE
DEPARTMENTS NOT COMMUNICATING
WITH US ABOUT THEIR PROBLEMS HOW
CAN WE HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT.
EVEN THE BANDAID AS YOU DESCRIBE
IT IS GOING TO DO WHAT'S
NECESSARY TO HAVE PEOPLE
PROPERLY IN THE LEGAL MARKET
PLACE.
FOLLOWING ALL THE RULES IS THAT
AS MANY THE MOVE INDICATED BY
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP AND
REQUEST A LICENSE SO I THANKYOU.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND LOOK TO
MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IDENTICAL
JOHNNY --
CENTER MCGUIRE I'M NOT THAT
FAMILIAR WITH THE LICENSURE
PROCESS WAS IT CDFA THAT CAME UP
WITH THE STEPS THAT WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN GIVING THE LICENSES.
AS FAR AS CREATING THAT THE
STEPS IN DAYS FOR TEMPORARY
STEPS IN DAYS FOR PROVISIONAL
YET NO THEY THEY DID NOT COME UP
WITH THAT --
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
ADHERE TO IT --
AND WHAT I'LL SAY IS THAT WE ARE --
WOEFULLY BEHIND IN THE
PROCESSING.
THERE'RE OUT AND I'LL LET THAT%
THE DEPARTMENT SPEAK FROM THE
CELLS ON WHY THEY BELIEVE --
WHEN THEY BELIEVE IT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE BUT LOOK --
I'VE ALWAYS SAID THIS.
IT'S GONNA TAKE US TEN YEARS. TO
BE ABLE TO YOU SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION.
FROM.
IN ILLICIT MARKET. TWO A
REGULATED LEGAL MARKET.
I HAVE ALWAYS.
SAID THAT.
PROVIDING THIS STATE. ONE YEAR.
TO PREPARE AFTER PROP SIXTY FOUR
WAS SETTING THIS UP FOR
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THESE
CHALLENGES ARE NOW HERE ON OUR
PLATE AND IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ONE
SILVER BULLET BUT WHAT I WOULD
HOPE.
IS THAT. TO A FIX ON THIS.
BUT THERE ARE EW THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO THROW OUT NUMBER ONE WE HAVE
TO GET THIS BILL PASSED SO WE
DON'T HAVE FOLKS WHO WERE LEGAL
NOW ENDING UP INTO THE ILLICIT
MARKET.
THAT THEN BY THIS TIME TO HAVE A
GREATER CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WOULD THEN BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE A LONG TRM FIX.
ON THE BACKLOG AND HOW WE GET
THESE FOLKS INTO THE ANNUAL
CATEGORY.
MY FINAL ITEM ON THIS --
IS.
IT'S IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME
THERE'S AN ENORMOUS.
AMOUNT OF DEMAND DOUBLY
COMPLICATED AND EXPENSIVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH.
AND I RIGHT NOW TIME IS NOT ON
OUR SIDE WE HAVE TO GET TO SING
MOVED WHAT I'M WONDERING IS IF
THE PROCESS IS EXTREMELY
CUMBERSOME AND IF THAT'S A PART
OF WHY.
THE DELAY CERTAINLY I'M SURE
RESOURCES IS PART OF IT
BUDGETARY RESOURCES BUT IF IF
FOR EXAMPLE SOMEONE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO GO OUT
TO TRAVEL OUT TO THE FACILITY.
AND LOOK AT THINGS AN EXAM AND I
WOULD SEE WHERE THAT WOULD
CREATE A TREMENDOUS BACKLOG AND
SO I'M WONDERING IF.
IF THEY HAVE THE ABILITY WITHIN
THEIR REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO
STREAMLINE AND AND SPEED UP THE
PROCESS SOMEHOW OR IF THAT WAS
HARD LINE IN THE BALLOT MEASURE
ITSELF AND DESCRIPTIVE IN THE
BALLOT MEASURE.
PERHAPS IT WAS TOO PRESCRIPTIVE
AND BUT ON THE OTHER HAND MAYBE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
CHANGED THROUGH THEIR REGULATORY
ABILITY.
I'LL BE THE THE FIRST TO SAY AND
I THINK THAT --
ARE TWO WITNESSES TODAY WILL BE
THE RIGHT THERE WITH ME THAT-THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING PROCESS TO GET
THROUGH AND IF YOU ARE A FARMER.
WHO HAD BEEN FARMING ON THE LAND
FOR THIRTY YEARS FOR YOUR SECOND
GENERATION YOU'RE TRYING TO BE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THE
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS OF BOTH THE
COUNTY IN THE STATE?
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME SO --
WHAT I'LL SAY IS THIS FIRST WE
ONLY ENGAGE WE BEING THE STATE
ONCE WE GET THE NOD FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTHAS
FOR SAY ON THE LICENSES?
THEY THEN ENTER INTO THE STATE
PROCESS -- I
DO I DON'T EVER WANT TO SPEAK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
LOOKING THOUGH AT SIXTY NINE
HUNDRED LICENSES AS WELL AS THE
NUMBER OF STAFF THAT THEY HAVE --
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES I AGAIN THAT'S JUST
ME SPEAKING MY OWN EDITORIAL ON
AND WOULD LOOK TO SEE IF THEY
NEED IN IN IN THIS IS A AN ITEM
THAT DAY CHAIR BROUGHT UP.
IS DO THEY NEED ENHANCE --
BUDGET TO BE A TO GET THIS
BACKLOG BURNED OFF ON IN WE
WELCOME THAT DISCUSSION BUT I
THINK WHAT WE NEED IS. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENGAGE ON THIS
CONVERSATION --
IN WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS THAT
THIS BILL WILL BE ONE OF THE
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE AT
THE TABLE DEVELOPING A LONG TERM
FIX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR PAN.
THE ROCHESTER REQUIRE.
I SERVICE BILLS IMPORTANT BILL --
TO TOO AGAIN NOT LEAD TO THE
COLLAPSE OF THE INDUSTRY --
THE GROWERS --
THESE MOVING THEM INTO THE BLACK
MARKET I'D NOTE THAT THE
DEADLINES IN THIS BILL MEAN THAT --
AT LEAST THOSE I'M SAYING THAT
MEANS THAT IN ADDITION TO THIS
BILL WHICH IS AN URGENCY BILL WE
ALSO NEED TO RAISE.
SO -- AND
AND I. S. ALSO A BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT --
SEE A FACE NOT HERE AS WELL SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS IS
THAT -- WELL
THIS BILLS BEFORE US AND I WILL
CERTAINLY BE VOTING FOR ITS AND
WOOD FACT FACT MET MOVE IT --
AT APPROPRIATE TIME --
WHAT OTHER STEPS ARE YOU LOOKING
AT THAT WILL THAT YOU INTEND
THAT WE SHOULD COMPLETE --
SO THAT BY THE TIME WE HIT
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN THE TEMPORARY
LICENSE EXPIRE AND THE
PROVISIONAL AYE LICENSE EXPIRES
AND TWENTY TWENTY THAT WE ARE
MOVING THIS BALL ALONG --
SO IT AND NOBODY YOU HAD SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER PAN --
THE THE SENATE HAS --
GOSH.
ANYA LOOKING SUCK ON THIS THREE
YERS AGO DEVELOP THE CANNABIS
WORKING GROUP IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY DID THE SAME --
SO [inaudible]
EACH.
HOUSE IS THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
HAVE.
FIRED UP THE WORKING GROUP'S
AGAIN ON AND WE HAVE MET --
IN BOTH AS MEMBERS AS WELL AS
STAFF OF TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM FIX.
THEIR AS BEEN THERE BEEN
MULTIPLE MEETINGS IN THE MONTH
OF JANUARY AS WELL AS THIS MONTH
BETWEEN --
THE RESPECTED --
COUNTIES THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEE --
NUMBER STAFF ON THE SENATE SIDE
AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY SIDE OF
TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS A LONGER
TERM FIX LOOK LIKE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED --
AND I'M NOT AT ALL TRYING TO BE
COY WITH YOU IT DOCTOR PAN --
I THINK WE'RE GONNA EED A FEW
MONTHS.
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LONGER TERM
FIX IS GOING TO BE.
AND BEING HONEST ABOUT IT WE
CAN'T DEVELOP A LONGER TERM FIX
WITHOUT THE ENGAGEMENT
ADMINISTRATION --
I GUESS I'LL JUST MENTION THAT
NIGHT AND PERHAPS A SUGGESTION --
FOR THE CHAIR WHETHER AT SOME
POINT WE SHOULD THIS COMMITTEE
OR THE PUBLIC COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
DO AN OVERSIGHT HEARING --
WITH THE AGENCY HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
READING THAT YOURS MINE YEAH
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN I HAD
CONVERSATION WITH CENTER MCGUIRE
EARLIER.
TODAY ABOUT THAT EXACT ISSUE AND
I THINK WE'RE BOTH LOOKING
FORWARD TO HIS COMMITTEE AND
OURS TOGETHER TRYING TO GET OUR
HANDS AROUND ALL THESE ISSUES NO
ONE LIKES TO BE SURPRISES I
THINK WE HAVE BEEN THIS YEAR --
WITH THIS PROBLEM AS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS VIA CENTER ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
I CAN HELP.
NEWS IN A LAW [inaudible]
MEETING AT FIVE AND WORKABLE --
OR BUT WHEN THIS [inaudible]
THAT -- HE
BOAT POSITIVE ON THIS.
ARE WE GONNA COME BACK AND EIGHT
MONTHS NINE MONTHS AND SAY THAT
THE TRAIN IT'S JUST NOT MOVING
AS FAST AS IT SHOULD BE.
HOW DO WE AVOID THAT BECAUSE I
THINK BY THE URGENCY ON THIS IT
IT GIVES THE FEELING THAT?
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OR A
SOLUTION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
THE AS TO BE AN INTERNAL
SITUATION.
THAT -- THAT
THE GROWERS AND EVERYONE ELSE
ARE BUT ARE NOT AT FAULT.
BUT HOW WE GONNA FIX THAT THAT'S
AN ISSUE AND IT IS IT'S ENOUGH
TIME.
ORDER WE COME BACK SEVEN EIGHT
NINE MONTHS FROM NOW ON IT'S A
ONLY 20% GOTTEN THROUGH. FORTY
FORTY WE WILL NOT HAVE A LONG
TERM SOLUTION IF THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT ENGAGE.
THE MINISTER IT'S TIME FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENGAGE IN THIS
ISSUE.
ARE THE ONLY WAY TO BE MY
OPINION --
IN WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO TRY TO
LOOK AT ADMINISTRATIVE FIXES I
AM NOT A BIG BELIEVER THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE TO BRING FOR THE
BILL. TO GET A FIX ON AN ISSUE
FACT THAT SHOULD BE THE LAST
RESORT.
BEING VERY HONEST WITH THE CHAIR
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
AT WE NEED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE. TO DEVELOP
A LONG TERM FIX COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY --
SO NEXT STEPS WILL BE.
CONTINUING TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN THE WORKING GROUP'S OF
BOTH THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
AND HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
ADMINISTRATION I DO KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS WITH --
CD AT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD NAG --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE.
TO HERE ANY SOLUTIONS WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY I'M HAVING
TO TAKE IN OUR OWN HANDS.
BUT I PROMISE YOU CENTER TO LET
A IT'S ABOUT MS OF MOST
IMPORTANCE.
CENTER GALGIANI UP DOES ANYBODY
KNOW WHETHER THE COUNTY LEVEL
PROCESS IS THE SAME COUNTY BY
COUNTY OR IS IT THAT CDFA HAS TO
DEAL WITH FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT.
LOCAL PROCESSES AND SO FORTH
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO THEN.
THERE I BELIEVE IT'S IN STATUTE --
COUNTIES HAVE SIXTY DAYS OF
DIFFERENT ORDINANCES SO THE
PROCESS FOR THE FOR THE
APPLICANT BASED ON EACH COUNTY
IS DIFFERENT BUT THE COUNTY DOES
NEED TO REPLY TO THE STATE WHEN
ASKED WITHIN SIXTY DAYS CORRECT.
BECAUSE I COULD SEE WHERE IF IF
I'M A STAFF MEMBER AT CDFA AND
I'M LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
LICENSE APPLICATIONS AND
EVERYTHING COMING MY WAY IS
DIFFERENT ALL THE FORMS ARE
DIFFERENT I HAVE TO LOOK IN
DIFFERENT PLACES TO FIND.
THE INFORMATION I COULD SEE
WHERE THAT WOULD SLOW THINGS UP
SOME JUST WONDERING IF THAT'S A
PART OF THE PROBLEM.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
CHALLENGES BUT I I MY BOTTOM
LINE AND CONTINUE TO COME BACK
TO IS WE'VE KNOWN THIS WAS GOING.
TO HIT US.
IN HIT US HARD ON IN THAT IS
WHERE.
I HAVE SOME FRUSTRATION I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THE CHAIR I BELIEVE HE
HAS SOME FRUSTRATION --
IN IT IS HUMAN NATURE.
ANYTIME.
ODD THAT I I KNOW I'M LIKE THIS
IF IT'S GOING TO COST ME A LOT
OF MONEY AND IT'S GONNA BE
COMPLICATED I'M GONNA WAIT TO
THE LAST MINUTE.
WE SAW AB.
SHOOT YOU RUSH. TO SECURE A
TEMPORARY LICENSE OF TO TEAM SO
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THERE --
CDFA SIDE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
APPLICATIONS COMING IN THOSE
LAST NINETY DAYS OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND IF IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND BAND WITH.
WITH --
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS THROUGH
BUDGET SUB TWO WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DRIVE DOWN THE SIXTY NINE
HUNDRED NUMBER.
SENATOR MCGUIRE WELL IT'S FAIR
TO SAY THAT THERE WERE  LOT
LAST MINUTE APPLICATIONS IS IT
ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT THERE WERE
HUNDREDS IF NOT.
THOUSANDS OF APPLICATIONS IN THE
EARLY PART OF THE YEAR.
YES OKAY THAT IS OF AN AND YOUR
SUMMARY IS THAT THAT CDFA IS
PROVIDED [inaudible] FOR FOR
CALL CULTIVATION Là ANNUAL
LICENSES IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME
FOR THEIR WEBSITE OKAY BECAUSE
I'M SENSITIVE TO A NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEY GET THE CHANCE TO GET
THEIR FEET ON THE GROUND FOR
SURE.
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY EXPLAIN --
IS A LOT MORE TO THE TO WHAT'S
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING --
CERTAINLY THE SENSITIVITY --
TO THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY ISSUE
IS GOOD BUT THE AT THAT WOULD BE
WHY WE SHOULD HAVE CDFA HERE.
GIVING US AN EXPLANATION AND I
THINK THAT I KNOW THE AUTHOR AND
CERTAINLY TO ME.
IS THAT WERE NOT GIVEN ANY
EXPLANATION FOR WHY WERE IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE.
BUT NOT JUST UNDERSTAND IT BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS HELPFUL.
IN DOING WHAT WE HAVE MUTUAL
GOALS TO ACCOMPLISH AND WE'RE
NOT EVEN CLEAR ON THAT ALTHOUGH
I THINK THIS LEGISLATION.
IS A NECESSARY STEP TO TAKE A
CENTER I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE HAVE YOUR FINAL COMMENTS --
I I A APPRECIATE --
WELL.
THE SITUATION THAT RAN IS
CREATED VERY UNNECESSARY
DISTRESS FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TO
OUT TO TRY TO HELP HELP THEM OUT
ANY FINAL COMMENTS SIR OF MAKE A
VERY QUICK I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU -- TO
THE CHAIR FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT UP
FOR HIS FOCUS --
IN HIS WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE IN THE MONTHS
TO COME.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WHO'S BEEN
ACTIVE IN ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THAT WE
WOULD NOT BE HERE WITHOUT THE
SILLIMAN --
AND ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO YOUR STAFF WHO CONTINUES TO
ENGAGE IN PROVIDE VALUABLE INPUT
ON A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO OUR
WITNESSES A RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR I AVE A MOTION FOR THE
SENATOR PAN.
AND IF THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHANG.
CHENG I. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE PAN PAN
AYE WILK HAVE SOME ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN.
MORE TO COME.
SENATOR JOHN NOT OKAY I'M TOLD
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARE NOT ABOUT
PLANNING TO ATTEND TODAY SO WHAT
IS THAT THOSE.
ARE AT THE MEASURES OUT A TWO
ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR REQUIRED
THANK YOU MEMBERS WERE WERE
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
IF